I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hi everybody. Hello.
我是珍娜·菲舍，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了这部《办公室》终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有亲历其中的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。女士们，我们就是《办公室》。大家好。你们好。
Are you guys ready for this episode today, Survivor Man? Do you have your duct tape? Oh boy. That's probably... Oh man. Do you have your duct tape and a Ziploc bag full of... What were those? Peanuts?
大家准备好迎接今天的这一集《荒野求生专家》了吗？你们带好强力胶带了吗？哦，天哪。那大概是……哦，天哪。你们带了强力胶带和一个装满……那些是什么？花生吗？
I have so many questions about it. Pellets? Granola? We don't know. And maybe a bow knife? Definitely a knife. Definitely always a knife for Survivor Man. I forgot to eat breakfast this morning before we got ready to record this podcast, Angela.
我对它有好多疑问。颗粒？麦片？我们不知道。也许还有一把弓形刀？肯定是一把刀。对荒野求生专家来说，肯定永远都是刀。安吉拉，今天早上我们准备录制这个播客之前，我忘了吃早餐。
So right before this moment, I ran downstairs and I ate an egg and a half of an apple. It hasn't digested yet, so I feel a little loopy. I feel a little bit like I'm in a good space for this episode. I'm a little bit like, you know, hungry, yeah, frazzled, yeah. Do you just have eggs ready to go? You know, I hard boil an egg first thing. When I wake up in the morning, I put an egg in my hard boiler. Okay.
所以在刚才那一刻，我跑下楼吃了一个半鸡蛋和一个苹果。它还没消化完，所以我感觉有点晕乎乎的。我觉得自己处于录制这一集的绝佳状态。我有点像，你知道的，饿了，对，心力交瘁，对。你随手就有煮好的鸡蛋吗？你知道的，我一大早就会煮个鸡蛋。早上醒来时，我就会把一个鸡蛋放进煮蛋器里。好吧。
And I just hadn't gotten back to it. So yeah, I had an egg ready to go. It's part of my morning process. Things you need to know about Jennifer, sure. Eggs, ruts to go. That's right. Add it to your list. Today is season four, episode 11, written by Steve Carell and directed by Paul Feig.
我只是还没顾上吃它。所以，是的，我备好了一个鸡蛋。这是我早晨流程的一部分。关于珍妮弗，你必须知道的事情，当然。随时可以吃的鸡蛋。没错。把它加到你的列表里。今天是第四季第十一集，由史蒂夫·卡瑞尔编剧，保罗·费格执导。
Here is a summary. Give it to me. After Ryan excludes Michael from a corporate wilderness retreat, Michael heads out into the woods for his own survival adventure with nothing but the suit on his back. Dwight secretly keeps watch. Back at the office, Jim tries to revolutionize the office birthday party system and learns that Michael's job is a lot harder than it looks. Oh yeah.
以下是剧情简介。讲给我听听。在瑞恩将迈克尔排除在一个公司荒野静修会之外后，迈克尔只穿着身上的一套西装，独自前往树林进行他自己的生存冒险。德怀特则在暗中监视。回到办公室，吉姆试图彻底革新办公室的生日派对制度，并发现迈克尔的工作比看上去要难得多。哦，是的。
And for those of you really paying attention, Jenna just gave us a Dwight. Did I? You did. I Krasinskied it. Pulled a Krasinski. Fast fact number one, this episode was written by our very own Steve Carell. Applause. We love you, Steve.
对于那些真正留心的人来说，珍娜刚刚给我们奉献了一个“德怀特”。我吗？你确实做了。我克拉辛斯基化了。来了一次克拉辛斯基式的操作。趣味冷知识一，这一集是由我们亲爱的史蒂夫·卡瑞尔编剧的。掌声。我们爱你，史蒂夫。
I love you. I reached out because I wanted to hear a little bit about the inspiration for this episode. Here's what Steve told me. He said that he and his wife Nancy loved this show called Survivor Man. So Steve pitched the idea for this episode because he and Nancy were such fans of the real show. What is Survivor Man? I've never seen the show.
我爱你。我联系了他们，因为我想听听这一集灵感的一些来源。史蒂夫是这么对我说。他说他和妻子南希非常喜欢一档叫《荒野求生专家》的节目。所以史蒂夫提出了这一集的创意，因为他和南希都是这个真实节目的超级粉丝。什么是《荒野求生专家》？我从没看过这个节目。
I mean, I'm guessing the guy's got to go survive somewhere. Oh, Angela, you're going to be so happy. What? Fast fact number two is all about the real Survivor Man show. Give it to me. It was a Canadian TV show starring a real life survival expert and filmmaker, Les Stroud. In each episode, he would be dropped off in a remote location and he would have to survive up to 10 days.
我的意思是，我猜那家伙得去什么地方求生吧。哦，安吉拉，你会非常高兴的。什么？趣味冷知识二全部关于真正的《荒野求生专家》节目。快告诉我。这是一档加拿大电视节目，主演是一位现实生活中的求生专家兼电影制作人莱斯·斯特罗德。在每一集中，他都会被空投到一个偏远地区，并且必须在那里生存长达10天。
He brought little or no food, water or equipment except for his camera equipment because he would film himself. There was no camera crew. But would he bring like a cup? Like how does he get water? No lady, no equipment. No utensil. Correct.
他几乎不带或根本不带食物、水或装备，除了他的摄影器材，因为他要自己拍摄自己。这里没有摄像团队。但他会带个杯子之类的吗？他怎么弄到水？没有，女士，没有装备。没有餐具。没错。
Hey, yeah, yeah. Now they did have safety precautions. Like you know in this episode how Dwight is kind of watching Michael from afar? Yeah. There was a support team who monitored the sky from a distance just in case he got attacked by a wild animal or something. They were not going to leave him out there to die. I would not be good at that job.
嘿，对，对。现在他们确实有安全防范措施。就像你知道的在这集里德怀特是如何远远地监视迈克尔的？是的。有一个支持团队从远处监控天空，以防他遭到野生动物袭击什么的。他们可不打算把他留在那里等死。这份工作我可干不好。
Like watching the man or being the man? Watching the man. I can't. I'm like, you know, I've got to put in my two cents. How would that work? Explain. Well, like maybe he starts to go for a bush or something. He shouldn't, you know, be touching.
是盯着那家伙，还是做那家伙？盯着那家伙。我做不到。我这人吧，你知道的，我总是得发表点高见。那会怎么运作？解释一下。嗯，就像他可能开始去碰某种灌木丛之类的。他不应该，你知道的，去碰它。
Maybe it's the poisonous bush. I don't know. I'd start going like, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, or I'd pretend to be a bird. But like it would be like, no, no, not that one. How can you watch someone struggle? I'd be horrible at that. Well, let me say this. He was allowed to scout and study these areas ahead of time with a team of local experts.
也许那是有毒的灌木。我不知道。我会开始发出“呃、呃、呃、呃、呃”的声音，或者我会假装是一只鸟。但这会像是，不，不，不是那一株。怎么能眼睁睁看着别人挣扎呢？我在这方面肯定糟糕透顶。好吧，我这么说吧。他是被允许提前带一队当地专家去勘察和研究这些地区的。
So he would go in with a survival plan. He would know the local fauna and flora. He would know what things he should eat or shouldn't eat. Something that Steve said was that he and Nancy noticed that the guy was always doing things like Michael does, like turning a stick into a spear. Like he's going to go spear an animal, but he never actually succeeded in actually killing an animal. So Steve and Nancy had a theory that he just really didn't want to kill any animals because
所以他带着生存计划进去。他会了解当地的动植物。他会知道哪些东西该吃，哪些东西不该吃。史蒂夫说过的一件事是，他和南希注意到那家伙总是做一些迈克尔那样的事，比如把一根树枝削成矛。就像他要去刺杀一只动物，但他实际上从来没有成功杀死过一只动物。所以史蒂夫和南希得出一个理论，那就是他真的不想杀死任何动物，因为
he was a really nice guy because he never seemed to actually catch any living food to eat. He was the friendly survivor man. Yeah. Fast fact number three is a location breakdown coming at you thanks to fan question from Catalina Rizzi, Sydney Weaver, Jason Barray, Sophia Spear, and Kate Betteridge. Where did Steve and Rain film the forest scenes? I'm going to guess the Los Angeles National Forest.
他是个真正的好人，因为他似乎从来没有真正抓到过任何活物来吃。他是友善的荒野求生专家。是的。趣味冷知识三是一个取景地大盘点，多亏了来自卡塔利娜·里齐、悉尼·韦弗、杰森·巴雷、索菲亚·斯皮尔和凯特·贝特里奇的粉丝提问。史蒂夫和雷恩是在哪里拍摄森林场景的？我猜是洛杉矶国家森林。
Hmm. I don't think so. Oh. I mean, unless the Los Angeles National Forest is at the 44 mile marker on the Los Angeles Crest Highway, because that's where we shot. These scenes were filmed at a picnic site called Charlton Flaps. And we spent one day shooting all of the forest scenes. And that day was, can I get a kentipedia from you, Angela, because kentipedia gave me this
嗯。我不这么认为。哦。我是说，除非洛杉矶国家森林正好在洛杉矶鹰冠公路的44英里路标处，因为那是我们拍摄的地方。这些场景是在一个叫做查尔顿平地的野餐地点拍摄的。我们花了一天时间拍摄了所有的森林场景。那一天是，安吉拉，我能从你这儿得到一个肯蒂百科吗，因为肯蒂百科给了我这个
information. Kenta, kenta, kentipedia. Thank you so much. You're welcome. Wednesday, October 17th, 2007. That's such a specific kentipedia fact. I know. So it was October and that is right when the chill starts to come over Los Angeles.
信息。肯塔，肯塔，肯蒂百科。非常感谢。不客气。2007年10月17日，星期三。这真是一个极具特定性的肯蒂百科冷知识。我知道。所以当时是10月，那正是洛杉矶开始变冷的时候。
So some of the stuff where Michael is like, it's so hot in the day and then it's cool at night. That's actually really accurate for us here in LA. That is life out here, guys. It's like you leave and you're like hot and then you're freezing in like four hours. It gets to layer. Yeah. It's a layering city for sure.
所以迈克尔说白天好热、晚上好凉的一些内容，对我们这里的洛杉矶来说其实非常准确。这就是我们这里的真实生活，各位。就像你出门时觉得热，然后大约四个小时后你就冻僵了。得穿叠穿。是的。这绝对是一个需要叠穿衣服的城市。
Yeah. Of course, our show was set in Scranton, Pennsylvania, so it would have been much colder than we depicted at that time in Scranton. For sure. We didn't get the weather right, guys. We got it wrong. We portrayed a nice October day in Southern California. That's all I got, lady.
当然，我们的节目背景设定在宾夕法尼亚州的斯克兰顿，所以当时斯克兰顿的天气肯定比我们表现出来的要冷得多。那是肯定的。我们把天气搞错了，各位。我们弄错了。我们把南加州的一个美好十月天描绘了出来。女士，我所知道的就这些了。
Well, this whole episode reminded me of Creed Bratton because, you know, Creed's my neighbor. He loves the show alone. It's like a survivalist show and he got Josh and I into it. And all I can think about when I watch these shows is, A, I would never make it. Not because I probably couldn't hunt and fish, but because I get too cold. What would do you in? I would get too cold. I think the lack of sleep.
嗯，整集节目让我想起了克里德·布拉顿，因为，你知道的，克里德是我的邻居。他超级喜欢《独自一人》这个节目。那是一个生存主义节目，他把乔什和我带进了这个坑。当我观看这些节目时，我脑子里想的全是，第一，我绝对坚持不下来。不是因为我可能不会打猎和钓鱼，而是因为我太怕冷了。什么会把你击垮？我会冷得受不了。我觉得是缺乏睡眠。
Whenever I watch shows like Survivor or like people doing extreme camping or survivalist type storylines, I always think about how they're not getting a sound night's sleep. And I really need that sleep. I am super cranky, but also I get physical symptoms when I don't sleep enough. I get a stomach ache. I get a headache. I get like real loopy. So I think it would be the lack of sleep that would do me in.
每当我观看诸如《幸存者》这样的节目，或者看人们进行极端露营或生存主义类型的故事情节时，我总是会想到他们根本无法安稳地睡上一觉。而我真的非常需要那种睡眠。我会超级暴躁，而且如果睡眠不足，我还会出现身体症状。我会胃痛。我会头痛。我会变得真的有点神志不清。所以我认为击垮我的会是缺乏睡眠。
I can sleep pretty much anywhere. I think I would figure out sleep, but I would just freeze to death or I'd get so cold I would get angry and then I'd quit. You're like, I am out of here. This is too effing cold. I'm out. Screw you guys. Where's my heater?
我基本上能在任何地方睡觉。我想我能解决睡眠问题，但我会直接被冻死，或者我会冷到发火，然后直接不干了。你会说，老娘不干了。这特么也太冷了。我不玩了。去你们的。我的暖气呢？
Well, my breakfast is kicking in, Ange, but I say we take a break and we'll come back to talk about one of my favorite opening scenes of an episode ever. Do you mean super sunburned Toby? Yes. Super happy sunburned Toby. All right, we'll be back. We are back and here it is, folks. Toby is holding court in the kitchen.
嗯，我的早餐开始起效了，安吉拉，但我建议我们休息一下，回来再聊聊我这辈子最喜欢的节目开场场景之一。你是说超级晒伤的托比吗？是的。超级快乐晒伤的托比。好吧，我们一会儿回来。我们回来了，各位，就是这个。托比在厨房里侃侃而谈。
I mean, he is the most lit up you will ever see Toby. I have to point out something while Toby is holding court for our background catch people at two seconds. You will see the jar of red vines that was in the kitchen for nine seasons. Yes. Primo shot. It's right behind Phyllis and I just looked at it and I started cracking up because I feel like those red vines would survive, you know, Armageddon because they were so shellacked
我是说，这是你见过的最容光焕发的托比了。当托比在厨房侃侃而谈时，我必须指出一件事，给我们的背景寻找彩蛋的人看，在两秒钟处。你会看到那罐陪伴了九季的红藤甘草糖。是的。绝佳的镜头。它就在菲莉丝身后，我刚刚看到它，然后我就忍不住爆笑了，因为我觉得那些红藤甘草糖即使经历世界末日也能存活下来，你知道的，因为它们被涂了一层厚厚的糖衣
and gross. Oh my gosh. You couldn't eat them. They were like sticks. Yeah. You remember opening them in season nine and they were the same as season one. It was scary. You know what?
而且黏糊糊的。哦，天哪。你根本吃不了它们。它们就像木棍一样。是的。你还记得在第九季打开它们时，它们和第一季里一模一样。太吓人了。你知道吗？
They should have taken those out into the woods. They could have used them to build their shelter. I'm a big red vines fan. I have to tell you when I go to the movies. Me too. Red vines or junior mints. Oh, that's so cute. Yeah.
他们本该把那些带进树林里去的。他们可以用它们来搭建避难所。我是红藤甘草糖的超级粉丝。我必须告诉你，当我去电影院时。我也是。红藤甘草糖或薄荷巧克力豆。哦，太可爱了。是的。
So Toby is chatting with Pam, Oscar, Phyllis and Meredith all about this wilderness retreat that he went on with Ryan and some of the other branch managers. We are hanging on his every word. We're laughing and you come to find out in this series of Talking Heads that Michael was not invited on the wilderness retreat. Three Talking Heads where the people say the same thing. Phyllis, Toby, you, Michael wasn't invited. He wasn't invited.
所以托比正在和帕姆、奥斯卡、菲莉丝以及梅雷迪思聊天，谈论他和瑞恩以及其他一些分公司经理一起去的那个荒野静修会。我们全神贯注地听着他的每一句话。我们都在笑，然后你在这一系列访谈中发现，迈克尔没有被邀请参加这个荒野静修会。三个访谈片段里人们都说着同一件事。菲莉丝、托比、你，迈克尔没有被邀请。他没被邀请。
Toby was. Michael wasn't. And the smile on Phyllis' face when she says it is amazing. She's so delighted that Michael wasn't invited. There is a delicious Talking Head that was deleted. It is Ryan in his office at corporate and he's saying how he had this idea for the retreat and corporate wouldn't pay for it. And he does that thing where he talks in third person where he's like, okay, Ryan, fix
托比去了。迈克尔没去。当菲莉丝说这话时，她脸上的笑容太棒了。她为迈克尔没被邀请感到无比高兴。有一个非常精彩的被删减的访谈片段。那是瑞恩在公司办公室里，他说他是如何萌生出静修会这个主意的，而公司却不肯为之买单。然后他做那个动作，就是用第三人称说话，他说，好吧，瑞恩，修复
it, got it, make it about the environment. He says make it a green retreat, then they pay for it. And then he goes on to say, no one ever does anything for the environment just to help the environment. If someone tells you they have a green initiative, it's a scam. Oh my gosh. And then he's saying that now that he's like the green wonder kid, you know, the green environmentalist that it's going to impress the ladies of the office and he purposefully
它，明白了，把它和环保挂钩。他说把它办成一个绿色静修会，然后他们就会买单。接着他继续说，根本没有人为了环保而去做任何有利于环保的事。如果有人告诉你他们有一个绿色倡议，那绝对是个骗局。哦，天哪。然后他说，既然他现在就像是绿色神童，你知道的，绿色环保主义者，这将会给办公室的女士们留下深刻印象，于是他故意
like puts a plastic water bottle in the recycle bin by a group of women and they don't even acknowledge him. It's hilarious. Well, we had a fan question about this scene from Stephanie Pollan, Catherine Loza, Zach James and Anthony Bataglia. Paul looks so tan. Does he have special sunburn makeup on to make it look like Toby has been camping? Yes.
把一个塑料水瓶扔进了一群女性旁边的回收桶里，而她们甚至都不搭理他。太搞笑了。好吧，我们收到了关于这个场景的粉丝提问，来自斯蒂芬妮·波兰、凯瑟琳·洛扎、扎克·詹姆斯和安东尼·巴塔利亚。保罗看起来晒得好黑。他是不是化了特殊的晒伤妆，好让托比看起来像是去露营了？是的。
Oh yeah. That was very thought out. They did a test run on his face. They took pictures. They decided if it was too much or too little. And I remember they even did his forehead, Jenna. Like where his hairline is. Yes.
哦，是的。那是经过深思熟虑的。他们在他的脸上进行了试妆。他们拍了照片。他们决定这是太过分了还是还不够。我记得他们甚至还化了他的发际线，珍娜。就像他头发长出来的地方。是的。
They did a great, great job. It really sells it. It looks real. Well, Michael is so stung by this. Oh, he's devastated. He's seething. He just like can't believe that Toby was invited to this over him. And Jenna, he starts asking people hypothetically if they would go camping with him.
他们做得非常非常棒。真的很逼真。看起来就像真的一样。嗯，迈克尔对此感到深深的刺痛。哦，他心碎了。他气急败坏。他简直不敢相信托比受邀参加这个活动而他却没有。而且，珍娜，他开始假设性地问大家愿不愿意跟他一起去露营。
In the deleted scenes, he starts with Pam and it's cut out and I wish it was in. Pam and Jim clearly have two different strategies with Michael because Pam is like, if Michael asked you a hypothetical, you always say no because his hypothetical could become an actually and you just say no. And then he doesn't make any leeway with you. So he moves on to Jim. But there is a great scene that clearly you and Jim kind of work together to avoid Michael to set up what you're about to listen to you guys.
在被删减的场景中，他从帕姆开始，但这被剪掉了，我真希望它能保留下来。帕姆和吉姆对付迈克尔明显有两套不同的策略，因为帕姆觉得，如果迈克尔问你一个假设性问题，你永远都得说不，因为他的假设可能会变成现实，所以你只要说不就行了。然后他就从你这儿得不到任何进展。于是他转向吉姆。但有一个精彩的场景，显然你和吉姆合作来躲避迈克尔，好为你们接下来要听的内容做铺垫。
Jim is in Michael's office and he asked her hypothetically would she go camping with him. She's like, no. So he's going to move on to Jim. He's like, is Jim there? She looks at his desk. Jim's not there. But she knows the minute Michael's like, can you send in Dwight? Dwight's going to be put on the tracking of Jim.
吉姆在迈克尔的办公室里，迈克尔假设性地问她愿不愿意和他一起去露营。她说，不。所以他打算去找吉姆。他说，吉姆在那儿吗？她看了看他的座位。吉姆不在。但她知道，只要迈克尔一说“你能把德怀特叫进来吗”，德怀特就会被派去追踪吉姆。
And so she runs to the break room to tell Jim to like hide and it's just so hilarious. And here's the clip. Is Jim out there? No. Can you send Dwight in here? Yeah. Dwight, Michael wants to see you in his office. You wanted to see me?
于是她跑进茶水间告诉吉姆去藏起来，这实在是太搞笑了。片段如下。吉姆在外面吗？不在。你能把德怀特叫进来吗？好的。德怀特，迈克尔让你去他办公室一趟。你找我？
Mm-hmm. I have something very personal I would like to discuss. Would you go find Jim and send him in here please? I'm on it. Michael has employed Dwight to track you down. How much time do I have? Jim, Michael's office. A couple minutes, give or take.
嗯。我有一件非常私人的事想跟你商量。你能去找一下吉姆并把他叫到这儿来吗？交给我吧。迈克尔已经雇了德怀特来追踪你了。我还有多少时间？吉姆，去迈克尔办公室。两分钟，上下浮动。
Now Jim. Oh my gosh, I love that. How many times was Michael looking for Jim and him and Pam had this covert thing where she's like, Dwight's looking for you. You have five minutes. It's so good. But you know Dwight does find Jim, right? So now Jim is in Michael's office and Michael is asking Jim, hypothetically would you like
现在，吉姆。哦，天哪，我太喜欢这个了。迈克尔找过吉姆多少次，而他和帕姆总有这种秘密暗号，她会说：德怀特在找你。你还有五分钟。太棒了。但你知道德怀特确实找到了吉姆，对吧？所以现在吉姆在迈克尔的办公室里，迈克尔正在问吉姆，假设性地问他愿不愿意去露营。
to go camping? And Jim's strategy is totally different from Pam's. Jim's like always say yes, right? But then have an excuse and apparently Jim's excuse is always that he's donating blood. Which I loved. I loved Steve's delivery as Michael when he says, how many times can a person give blood? Yeah. Jim says, is there a limit?
而吉姆的策略跟帕姆完全不同。吉姆的策略是永远说好，对吧？但随后要找个借口，显然吉姆的借口总是他在献血。我太喜欢这个了。我太喜欢史蒂夫扮演迈克尔时的台词演绎了，当他说：“一个人到底能献多少次血？”是的。吉姆说：“有什么限制吗？
I didn't know. I remember John breaking every single time that Steve as Michael said, your body only has a certain amount. Yeah. That John would lose it. Do you remember that? I do because I was in the background at reception. I think at two minutes, nine seconds, you can see John trying not to break.
我不知道。”我记得每次史蒂夫饰演的迈克尔说“你的身体只有那么多血”时，约翰都会笑场。对。约翰总是会崩溃。你还记得吗？我记得，因为当时我在前台背景里。我想在大约两分钟零九秒时，你能看到约翰在努力憋笑。
Also when Michael was talking to Jim about Ryan's lame camping trip that he clearly wanted to go on. He's kind of making fun that they did s'mores and he's like, hello, I'm broken mountain. You know. And this is this moment, Jenna, where I felt like Michael was my mom because my mom would never get the name broke back mountain, correct? My mom would probably think it was broken mountain. Yes.
还有当迈克尔跟吉姆谈论瑞恩那个逊毙了的露营之旅时，他显然很想去。他有点在嘲笑他们烤了棉花糖，然后他说：“哈喽，我是断背山。”你知道的。就是在这个时刻，珍娜，我觉得迈克尔就像是我妈妈，因为我妈妈绝对会把“断背山”这个名字说错，对吧？我妈妈可能会以为它是“断山”。是的。
My mom is always one word off. My mom is the same way, are we going to be like that, Angela? I think I already am. I feel like we're starting to turn into that. I went to say, like, let's FaceTime the other day and I said, why don't we Facebook? There it is. I know. That's classic mom brain right there.
我妈妈总是差一个字。我妈妈也是这样，安吉拉，我们会不会也变成那样？我觉得我已经开始变了。我有一天想说“我们FaceTime吧”，结果我说的是“为什么我们不Facebook呢”。就是这样。我知道。这就是典型的妈妈脑。
It's happening. Well, then Michael has a talking head where he explains that when he and Jan had satellite TV, I guess maybe they turned it off because of their money problems. But yes, this is the thing we love. This is the callback to money, right? Yeah. They're on a budget now. Oscar has given them a budget.
它正在发生。嗯，然后迈克尔有一个访谈片段，他在里面解释说，当他和简拥有卫星电视时，我猜可能是因为他们的金钱问题把电视停了。但没错，这就是我们喜欢的东西。这就是对《金钱》那一集的呼应，对吧？是的。他们现在精打细算。奥斯卡给他们做了一个预算。
I also want to point out that when we get to the dinner party episode and we see Michael's new flat screen TV, just remember that has no satellite television on it as established in this episode. That's great. Anyway, he says that he and Jan used to watch a show called Survivorman and it's all about this guy who survives in the wild and so Michael is going to do this because this is real wilderness adventure. So he tells Dwight, I need two things, a roll of duct tape and a knife.
我还想指出的是，当我们看到《晚餐派对》那一集并看到迈克尔的新平板电视时，请记住，正如这一集所确定的那样，那上面是没有卫星电视的。太棒了。不管怎样，他说他和简以前看一档叫《荒野求生专家》的节目，内容全部关于一个在野外生存的家伙，所以迈克尔也要这么做，因为这是真正的荒野冒险。于是他告诉德怀特：“我需要两样东西，一卷强力胶带和一把刀。
And I need it in 30 minutes or less. And Dwight's like on it. No problem. I did a little bit of a breakdown of the weaponry in the office. Oh, there's so much Dwight goes around the office collecting weapons that he's hidden. Lady, look at my documentation. You really did document it. There's numbers.
而且我需要在30分钟内搞定。”德怀特一副包在我身上的样子。没问题。我对办公室里的武器做了一个小小的盘点。哦，有太多了。德怀特在办公室里到处收集他藏起来的武器。女士，看看我的文档。你真的做了文档记录。上面有数字。
They're numbered. How many are there? Okay. Guess how many weapons are in the office? I'm not talking about what he has in his car because we know he has stuff in the trunk of his car. Okay. Just guess what he has stashed in the office.
它们有编号。有多少个？好吧。猜猜办公室里有多少武器？我不是指他在车里藏的东西，因为我们知道他车后备箱里有东西。好吧。就猜他在办公室里藏了多少。
How many? Eight. Twenty-three. What? Now listen, office fans, if I got it wrong, let me know. But this is what I tracked and I went back and rewatched the negotiation. So ready? In the negotiation taped underneath his desk are pepper spray and throwing stars.
多少？八个。二十三个。什么？现在听好了，办公室的粉丝们，如果我数错了，请告诉我。但这就是我追踪到的结果，我又回去重看了《谈判》那一集。准备好了吗？在《谈判》中，贴在他办公桌底下的有辣椒水和飞镖。
In his desk drawer are nunchucks, a Billy Club looking thing. And listen, my weapons experts, if I get some of these names wrong, just, you know, you'll let me know. Then there's also handcuffs, a taser, another throwing star, what looks like to be a whip, nuts, knuckles, and a boomerang. That's just in the negotiation. And in this episode, under Meredith's desk are, like he rolls out a set of like eight different types of knives.
他的办公桌抽屉里有双节棍，一个看起来像比利棍的东西。听好了，我的武器专家们，如果我把其中一些名字叫错了，你们就，你知道的，会告诉我。然后还有手铐、一把电击枪、另一个飞镖、看起来像鞭子的东西、指虎和一个回旋镖。这还只是在《谈判》那一集里。而在这一集里，梅雷迪思的桌子底下有，就像他滚出一套大约八种不同类型的刀具。
Two pitchfork dagger looking things are behind the water cooler. There's a giant knife in the file cabinets by Kevin's desk. There's a samurai sword in the ceiling over Stanley and Phyllis's desk. And then finally he has blowdarts in the men's restroom, like in the back of the toilet. What do you call the back of the toilet thing? The tank? The tank. Yes.
饮水机后面有两个像干草叉一样的匕首。凯文的办公桌旁边的文件柜里有一把巨型刀。斯坦利和菲莉丝的办公桌上方的天花板里有一把武士刀。最后他在男卫生间里有吹箭，就在马桶后面，那个马桶后面的东西叫什么来着？水箱？水箱。是的。
So when I added them all up, you guys, I counted 23 weapons in the office. It's quite a menagerie of weaponry. A menagerie of weapons, Dwight. And I don't know what those pitchfork dagger thingies are called, and I'm sure you guys will let me know. But that's what they look like to me. I don't know what those were either. They seemed like they would be really good for roasting marshmallows, even though I understand
所以当我把它们全部加起来时，各位，我数出办公室里有23件武器。这真是一个武器大杂烩。一个武器大杂烩，德怀特。我不知道那些叉子样的匕首叫什么名字，我确信你们会告诉我的。但它们在我看来就是那样。我也不知道那些到底是什么。它们看起来好像非常适合烤棉花糖，尽管我明白
they're a weapon. It seemed like a really great triple marshmallow roaster. Mmm, yeah. I got really interested for whatever reason in the blow dart gun. Oh, okay. So guess what I have for you. Do you have a deep dive on blow dart guns? I sure do.
它们是武器。它看起来像是一个非常棒的三重棉花糖烤架。嗯，是的。不管出于什么原因，我对吹箭枪产生了浓厚的兴趣。哦，好吧。所以猜猜我为你准备了什么。你对吹箭枪有深入研究吗？我当然有。
Oh, lady, lady, give it to me. Here it is. From what I could find, the blow dart seems to have been invented in ancient times and probably in Southeast Asia. They started as bamboo tubes that shot out seeds and clay pellets and then eventually graduated to poison darts. Now, Angela, you might find this interesting because it is believed that it was Indonesian traders that took the blow gun to Japan, South India, Madagascar, and they also popped
哦，女士，女士，快告诉我。就是这个。据我所能查到的资料，吹箭似乎是在古代发明的，很可能在东南亚。它们最初是用竹管发射种子和泥丸，然后逐渐升级为毒镖。现在，安吉拉，你可能会觉得这很有趣，因为人们认为正是印尼商人把吹箭筒带到了日本、南印度、马达加斯加，它们也
up in South America, Middle America, and the Eastern United States. That's Indonesian for, oh my goodness. There we go. Dart guns were primarily used for hunting, not combat. I feel like in movies we always see them used in combat scenes, right? But they were actually a hunting device. The North American Cherokees were known for using them to hunt rabbit and other small creatures and blow guns are still used today.
出现在南美洲、中美洲和美国东部。那是印尼语的“哦，天哪”。就是这样。镖枪主要用于打猎，而不是战斗。我觉得在电影里我们总是看到它们被用于战斗场景，对吧？但它们实际上是一种狩猎工具。北美切罗基人以用它们狩猎兔子和其他小动物而闻名，而且吹箭筒今天仍在使用。
There are even sport blow gun competitions, Angela, and some groups are trying to make it an Olympic event. I would watch that. Yeah. The blow dart event. I'm there. Lady, can we go to a blow dart competition? I'm fascinated.
甚至还有竞技吹箭比赛，安吉拉，一些团体正试图将其列为奥运会项目。我会看那个的。是的。吹箭项目。算我一个。女士，我们能去参加一个吹箭比赛吗？我太着迷了。
Can we go to a blow dart master and get trained on how to blow dart? I'm up for all of it. After researching the blow dart, I'm like, bring it on. Bring it on. I'll tell you what. One of my improv teams, we had a player who would sometimes hog the stage and just not leave the stage and take over every scene. So a bunch of us started improv blow darting him.
我们能去找一个吹箭大师，接受如何使用吹箭的培训吗？我举双手赞成。在研究了吹箭之后，我只想说，放马过来吧。放马过来。我跟你说。我的一个即兴喜剧团队里，有一个演员有时会独占舞台，就是不肯离开舞台，还掌控了每一个场景。所以我们一群人开始在即兴表演中对他使用吹箭。
We just go like, he'd have to pass out and we just start blow darting him in scenes. That is very funny. He was the Michael of your class. Yeah. Well, guys, Michael is ready to go. He comes out of his office and he tells Pam that he and Dwight are leaving. Dwight will return later and Michael will be taking a personal day tomorrow and perhaps for the next two days.
我们就会发出“嘘”的声音，他不得不假装昏倒，然后我们就在场景中开始朝他发射吹箭。这太搞笑了。他就是你们班的迈克尔。是的。好吧，各位，迈克尔准备好了。他从办公室出来，告诉帕姆他和德怀特要出发了。德怀特稍后会回来，迈克尔明天将请一天个人假，也许接下来的两天也是如此。
And Pam is like, do you want me to ask you where you're going? Yeah. And he says, no. And then he tells her anyway. Of course. I noticed Dwight is standing behind Michael this whole speech. He is holding four things. He is holding a camera, the same camera that we used to make Michael's apology video, a
然后帕姆说，你想让我问你要去哪儿吗？是的。然后他不管怎样还是告诉了她。当然。我注意到德怀特在迈克尔发表这段演讲时一直站在他身后。他手里拿着四样东西。他拿着一个摄像机，就是我们用来制作迈克尔道歉视频的那个摄像机，一卷
roll of duct tape, one of the giant knives, and a bag of what? What is it? What is it? I zoomed in. I took a picture of it. I can't tell. At first I was like, is it peanuts? There's no way it's peanuts.
强力胶带，其中一把巨型刀，还有一个袋子，里面是什么？是什么？是什么？我放大了镜头。我拍了张照片。我看不出来。起首我还在想，是花生吗？绝对不可能是花生。
It's also so full. It looks like the pellets you feed your hamster. That's what it looks like to me. It looks like some sort of animal kibble. I don't know. Like he's going to sprinkle around to attract animals? Well, we never see him eat it. We never see him use what's in the bag.
而且装得那么满。看起来就像你喂仓鼠的颗粒饲料。在我看来就是那样。看起来像某种动物饲料。我不知道。就像他打算撒在周围来吸引动物吗？好吧，我们从没见他吃过。我们从没见他使用袋子里的东西。
He uses the other three things. I don't know. We see him only hold the bag of question mark. That's right. Also in this scene, I love that Michael announces that when he comes back, he is going to be a completely changed human being. And then Jim says, that would be great. So good.
他用了另外三样东西。我不知道。我们只看到他拿着那个装满问号的袋子。没错。也在这个场景中，我非常喜欢迈克尔宣布，等他回来时，他将是一个脱胎换骨的全新人类。然后吉姆说，那太好了。太棒了。
Dwight, of course, has this talking head, which is really funny where he's like, no, he doesn't believe Michael would survive in the wilderness. Super matter of fact. But lady, I have to point out something at five minutes, 19 seconds. What is it? Why are Michael and Dwight in a 2006 or 2007 give or take PT Cruiser? I think we have a car switch. Is this an extension of Michael's money stuff where he said they traded in both their cars
德怀特当然有个访谈片段，非常搞笑，他在里面说，不，他不相信迈克尔能在荒野中生存。超级实事求是。但女士，我必须在五分钟零十九秒时指出一件事。什么事？为什么迈克尔和德怀特坐在一辆2006年或2007年左右的PT酷派里？我想我们车子换了。这是迈克尔金钱事情的延伸吗，就是他说他们用两辆车去置换了那辆保时捷，然后他们把保时捷卖了，现在他换了一辆PT酷派？哦，天哪。
for that Porsche and did they get rid of the Porsche and now he has a PT Cruiser? Oh my gosh. We need someone to figure this out. We do. And I looked up the PT Cruiser. This is around the 2007 make with the red interior. I Googled it. Why is Michael having a Chrysler PT Cruiser?
我们需要有人弄明白这件事。我们确实需要。我查了一下PT酷派。这是大约2007年的车型，配有红色内饰。我谷歌了一下。为什么迈克尔会开一辆克莱斯勒PT酷派？
I need to know why. Who could we ask? I don't know. Guys, this is one of those moments where you can see so clearly that we are not the experts of the office. Perhaps there is a really obvious answer for this. Like remember when I declared that Pam had never used the shredder and then several episodes later she clearly uses the shredder and take your daughter to work day.
我需要知道为什么。我们可以问谁呢？我不知道。各位，这就是那些能让你非常清楚地看到我们其实并非《办公室》专家的时刻之一。也许这有一个非常显而易见的答案。就像还记得我曾断言帕姆从未用过碎纸机，结果好几集之后她在《带女儿上班日》里分明就用了碎纸机。
It is very possible that we missed why he's driving a PT Cruiser. Someone tell us. Let us know. This is going to keep me up at night and you know how I do with no sleep. Let her know. And while they're in this PT Cruiser, Angela, Michael is explaining to the camera what's happening. We are to assume that Michael is being driven to the forest by a serial killer who's going
我们非常有可能漏掉了他为什么开PT酷派的原因。谁来告诉我们一声。让我们知道吧。这会让我整晚睡不着觉，而且你知道我睡眠不足时的德行。让她知道。当他们坐在PT酷派里时，安吉拉，迈克尔正在向镜头解释发生了什么。我们要假设迈克尔是被一个打算把他抛弃等死的连环杀手开车带到森林里的，但迈克尔会活下来。
to leave him for dead but Michael is going to survive. The overkill killer, as Dwight calls himself. Yes. He says, if I were your serial killer, you would never survive. I have a fan question from Elizabeth Congdon and Matthew Lister. In this scene in the car Dwight takes off his shoe and hits Michael in the head. Was the shoe hit, planned or improvised? And Joey Carr would like to know, was that an actual shoe or did Phil Shea have to make
也就是他自称的“赶尽杀绝杀手”。是的。他说：“如果我是你的连环杀手，你绝对活不下来。”我收到了来自伊丽莎白·康贡和马修·利斯特的粉丝提问。在车里的这个场景中，德怀特脱下鞋子砸了迈克尔的头。鞋子砸头这一幕是计划好的还是即兴发挥的？乔伊·卡尔想知道，那是真鞋还是菲尔·谢伊不得不
a shoe out of rubber or some other soft material that wouldn't hurt Steve? I asked Steve about this. Yeah. First of all, it was planned. It was in the script. It was not improv. Steve believes it was a real shoe. He is not sure.
用橡胶或其他不会伤害史蒂夫的软质材料制作鞋子？我问过史蒂夫这件事。是的。首先，这是计划好的。剧本里写了。这不是即兴发挥。史蒂夫相信那是一只真鞋。他也不太确定。
I zoomed in on it. It looked like a real shoe. Steve said maybe the reason he can't remember is because it was a real shoe. And so he's going with real shoe. I zoomed in on it too, Jenna. Not only do I think it was a real shoe, I actually think it's Dwight's shoe. I think it came off Rain's foot. It looks exactly like the shoes he wore.
我把镜头放大了。看起来像是一只真鞋。史蒂夫说也许他记不清的原因是因为那是一只真鞋。所以他认为那就是真鞋。我也放大了镜头，珍娜。我不但认为那是真鞋，我甚至觉得那是德怀特的鞋。我觉得那是从雷恩脚上脱下来的。看起来跟他穿的鞋一模一样。
Yes. I can't imagine that Phil Shea was able to make a replica foam shoe. That was a real shoe. Back in the office, there's some drama. I guess Jim has been put in charge of things because of Michael's absence and Angela goes up to Jim to talk about ordering a cake for Creed's birthday. Well she lets him know it's birthday month. And you guys, we all have birthday month, right?
是的。我无法想象菲尔·谢伊能做出一双泡沫假鞋。那绝对是真鞋。回到办公室，有些抓马。我猜因为迈克尔不在，吉姆被委以重任，安吉拉走到吉姆面前谈论为克里德的生日订蛋糕的事。好吧，她告诉他现在是生日月。大家伙儿，我们都有生日月，对吧？
Our birthday month in my family is May. All three kids are born in May, my mother-in-law is born in May, two of my sisters are born in May. We call it birthday palooza. Jenna, what's your birthday month? Our birthday month was March. When I was growing up, me, my sister, and my mom are all born in March. So we had three birthdays in one month.
我家里的生日月是五月。三个孩子都在五月出生，我婆婆在五月出生，我的两个姐姐也在五月出生。我们管它叫生日狂欢月。珍娜，你的生日月是什么时候？我们的生日月是三月。我小时候，我和我妹妹还有我妈妈都是三月出生的。所以我们一个月过三个生日。
I'm telling you, every family has one. And at Dunder Mifflin, this is birthday month. Creed's is today. Oscars is a week after next. Meredith is at the end of the month. And we also find out later in this episode from Creed that Jim's was three weeks ago and there's a series of talking heads about birthdays. Angela says, you know what, if this is birthday month, jog back nine months.
我跟你说，每个家庭都有这样一个月份。在邓德米夫林，这就是生日月。克里德的是今天。奥斯卡的是下周之后的一周。梅雷迪思的是月底。而且我们在这一集后面从克里德那儿得知，吉姆的生日是三周前，还有一系列关于生日的访谈。安吉拉说：“你知道吗，如果这是生日月，往前推九个月。
You know what that was, Valentine's Day. And then she tells everyone, stagger your sin, stagger your sin so we don't have birthday month. And Jenna, Kelly has a talking head about the birthdays. And I'm just going to show you a screen grab because I really need it to just be a surprise. I want you to read. I put the subtitles on last night. I want you to read what Kelly says about Pam because this is a little bit of Kelly's
你知道那是什么时候吗，情人节。”然后她告诉大家：“错开你们的罪过，错开你们的罪过，这样我们就不会有生日月了。”而且珍娜，凯莉有一个关于生日的访谈。我正要给你看一个屏幕截图，因为我真的希望它是一个惊喜。我想让你读一读。我昨晚打开了字幕。我想让你读一下凯莉对帕姆的评价，因为这有点带有了凯莉的
shade. Oh my gosh. Read out loud what Kelly says about you. Pam lies about her age. That's amazing. There's a great runner of talking heads that were deleted and that's part of Kelly Kapoor's. Well, I'll tell you something. In real life, I am five years older than John Krasinski.
毒舌。哦，天哪。大声读出凯莉对你的评价。帕姆谎报年龄。太棒了。这里有一系列很棒的被删减的访谈，那是凯莉·卡普尔的内容之一。好吧，我跟你说件事。在现实生活中，我比约翰·克拉辛斯基大五岁。
Scandalous. I know. But on the show, our characters were meant to be the same age. I couldn't tell. So I think they made Jim a little bit older than John and they made Pam a little younger than me. You met in the middle. Well, I want to point out two things at six minutes, five seconds during this whole conversation
耸人听闻。我知道。但在节目中，我们的角色被设定为同龄人。我看不出来。所以我认为他们把吉姆设定得比约翰稍大一点，而把帕姆设定得比我年轻一点。你们在中间相遇了。好吧，我得在六分钟零五秒时指出两件事，就在安吉拉和吉姆的整场对话期间，顺便说一下，这一集是吉姆和安吉拉迄今为止互动最多的一集。这是他们俩有史以来说话最多的一次。
between Angela and Jim, which, by the way, this episode was the most Jim and Angela have interacted so far to date. This is the most they've ever had to speak to each other. Huge Janjala storyline. Janjala storyline. At six minutes, five seconds, Jenna, this is the return of the puffy elbow sweater. Oh, it's so unattractive. I'm sorry, lady.
巨大的简杰拉剧情线。简杰拉剧情线。在六分钟零五秒时，珍娜，这是那件泡泡袖毛衣的回归。哦，太难看了。对不起，女士。你的脸，你的刘美，你的皮肤在发光。你看起来美极了。但这件上衣是个悲剧。他们为什么会买两种颜色？记住，我在《发布会派对》里穿过米色版本的。是的。
Your face, your bangs, your skin is glowing. You look gorgeous. This top is a tragedy. Why did they buy it in two colors? Remember, I wore it in the beige version of launch party. Yeah. Well, it's back. Now it's in maroon.
好吧，它又回来了。现在是褐红色。所以我们有了这个。但我前台的植物，各位，在吉姆的肩膀上方，我们能看到前台正前方的植物。那是一株盛开的植物。哦。哇。什么？是一株粉红色的红掌。
So we've got that going. But my plant at reception, people, over Jim's shoulder, we see the plant at front reception. It is a blooming plant. Oh. Whoa. What? It is a pink antherm. Huh.
盛开的。嗯哼。前台正前方盛开的植物。女士，吉姆有个宏大的想法，而这个想法不会顺利通过。确实不会。这气得所有人简直都要抓狂了。吉姆建议他们只办一场盛大的派对，而不是在这个月的过程中办好几场派对。
Blooming. Uh-huh. Blooming plant at front reception. Lady, Jim has a big idea that is not going to go over well. It is not. It pisses literally everyone off. Jim suggests that they just do one big party rather than several parties over the course of the month.
安吉拉不喜欢。没有人会喜欢这个想法。是的。你知道的，我才不会喜欢那样呢。在我的家庭里长大，我可不想跟我妹妹或我妈妈共享生日。在我家里，我们的传统是你可以挑选你的蛋糕，你可以挑选你的晚餐。
Angela doesn't like it. No one's going to like this idea. Yeah. You know, I wouldn't have liked that. Growing up in my family, I don't want to share a birthday with my sister or with my mom. In my house, our tradition was that you got to pick your cake and you got to pick your dinner.
在你的生日那天，我和我妹妹喜欢不同的晚餐和不同的蛋糕。这跟办公室里即将发生的事情非常相似。每个人都想要他们自己的小玩意儿。嗯哼。接下来，我们有一个吉姆的访谈，伴随着一个精彩的生日惊喜蒙太奇片段。安吉拉，我们收到关于这个访谈的邮件比我们以往任何访谈收到的都要多。
On your birthday, and my sister and I like different dinners and different cakes. And it's very similar to what's going to happen in the office. Everybody wants their own little thing. Uh-huh. Next up, we have a Jim talking head that has a wonderful montage that goes along with it of birthday surprises. Angela, we got more mail about this talking head than any talking head I think we've ever had.
是因为所有那些不同的生日派对吗？不。好吧，我拍了张照片，因为在这个所有不同生日派对的蒙太奇片段中，有一个时刻是我们所有人都在毫无形象地大笑。哦，是的。我们完全出戏了。那是当布莱恩拿起充气娃娃，用它猛砸雷恩的脑袋时。那是他们即兴发挥的。
Is it about all the different birthday parties? No. Well, I took a picture because in this montage of all the different birthday parties, there is a moment where we are all just flat out laughing. Oh, yeah. We've completely broken character. And it's when Brian takes the blow-up doll and is beating rain over the head with it. They improvised that.
那是他们犯蠢而已。很多人想知道我们在所有这些片段中到底笑得有多厉害。我们的冰淇淋抓拍了一个时刻，珍娜，你能看到我和埃德·赫尔姆斯还有奥斯卡都在爆笑。看那个。那根本不是安吉拉·马丁。太棒了。我会把那个截图发到快拍里。
That was just them being idiots. A lot of people wanted to know how much were we actually laughing in all of these clips. Our ice cream grabbed a moment, Jenna, where you can just see me and Ed Helms and Oscar just cracking up. Look at that. That is not Angela Martin. That is amazing. I will put that screen grab in stories.
有很多人写信指出，吉姆说办公室里有13个人。但难道不应该有14个人吗？我数过了。有14个。但基思·尼科尔斯说，吉姆是不是故意把托比漏掉了，就像迈克尔那样？哦。潜意识里。对吧？
We had a lot of people write in to point out that Jim says there are 13 people in the office. But shouldn't there be 14? I wrote it out. There's 14. But Keith Nichols said, is Jim leaving out Toby on purpose just like Michael would? Oh. Subconsciously. Right?
也许吧。是的。算上托比是14个，不算托比是13个。哦，你知道我觉得有趣的是，很显然帕姆知道这是个糟糕透顶的主意。她知道这是一场灾难。她走到吉姆面前说：“你觉得这是个好主意？”而他说：“我觉得是个绝妙的主意。”
Maybe. Yes. It's 14 with Toby, 13 without. Oh, you know what is interesting to me is that it's clear that Pam knows that this is a horrible idea. She knows it's a disaster. She goes up to Jim and is like, you think this is a good idea? And he's like, I think it's a great one.
然后她就一副“好吧，好吧”的表情。为什么帕姆什么都不说？我不知道她为什么不说，但吉姆在这里确实显得有点油盐不进，对吧？他似乎有点坚信自己有个绝妙的主意。我想她是觉得，好吧，那就顺其自然吧。让我们看看这会怎么发展，伙计。但她知道这会怎么发展。也许她只是需要让他自己去摸索。
And she just kind of smells like, no, okay. Why doesn't Pam say anything? I don't know why she doesn't, but Jim does seem a little immovable here, right? He seems a little convinced that he has a great idea. And I think she's like, okay, let's play it out. Let's see how this goes, buddy. But she knows how it's going to go. Maybe she just needs to let him figure it out.
他必须找到他自己的路。我想是的。各位，就在此时，德怀特和迈克尔已经抵达树林。迈克尔被蒙上了双眼，他要求德怀特引领他进入荒野。你们有没有注意到，德怀特是故意带着迈克尔穿过一片杂草丛，而不是领着他走平坦的清晰小路？是的。他说：“别担心。
He has to find his own way. I guess so. Guys, at this point, Dwight and Michael have arrived in the woods. Michael is blindfolded and he is asked Dwight to lead him into the wilderness. Do you notice how Dwight purposely takes Michael through a bunch of weeds rather than walk him on the clear path? Yeah. He's like, don't worry.
只是些灌木和杂树丛而已，”而他明明可以绕过去。在摘下眼罩之前，德怀特还坚持把迈克尔转了好几圈，我太喜欢这个了。他们在树林里的被删减场景实在是太多了。珍娜，这两个男人那一周都经历了些什么啊？我的意思是，他们在地上互相角力。有太多场景了，比如德怀特在学鸟叫。他在躲藏。
Just some bushes and some thickets when he clearly could have walked around them. Before removing his blindfold, Dwight also insists on spinning Michael around, which I loved. There are so many deleted scenes of them in the woods. Jenna, what these men went through that week? I mean, they wrestle each other to the ground. There's just so many scenes like Dwight is doing bird calls. He's hiding.
只有一些灌木丛和杂树林，而他明明可以绕过去。在摘下眼罩之前，德怀特还坚持把迈克尔转了好几圈，这我太喜欢了。他们俩在树林里的删减片段可太多了。珍娜，这些男人那周都经历了什么？我的意思是，他们把对方扑倒在地扭打。还有好多场景，比如德怀特在学鸟叫，他在躲藏。
Michael is exploring a ravine saying absolute nonsense. He's saying that like, yeah, this ravine was formed when the icebergs, like he's saying all this crazy stuff. And I kept thinking as I watched all this extra footage, what does Michael do with this footage? What does he do with all this? Who ever sees the stuff? I don't know.
迈克尔在峡谷里探索，嘴里说着一堆绝对无厘头的话。他说，哦，对啊，这个峡谷是冰山形成的，他就是说诸如此类疯狂的话。我在看所有这些多出来的素材时，一直在想，迈克尔拿这些素材做什么？他拿这些来做什么？到底谁会看这玩意儿？我不知道。
I think that all the time when I see people doing things like videotaping a fireworks display, you're going to watch that later. I know. You're going to watch that seven minute video of the fireworks. And by the way, while the fireworks are going off, you want to watch your phone screen? I don't get it. Yeah. No.
每当看到有人做那种给烟花表演录像之类的事情时，我总是这么想，你以后会去看那个的。我知道。你会去看那个七分钟的烟花视频。而且话说回来，在烟花绽放的时候，你想盯着你的手机屏幕看？我不理解。是的。不。
So Dwight has left Michael on his own. Of course, we know he's secretly watching him. And Michael has decided it's getting hot and he takes his knife. I was so worried about his leg the whole time, by the way, that he was going to like, sever his leg. Me too. He cuts his pants into shorts. He then decides to make a hat out of the extra material.
所以德怀特把迈克尔一个人留下了。当然，我们知道他暗中在看着他。迈克尔觉得天气变热了，于是拿出他的刀。顺便说一句，我全程都很担心他的腿，担心他会把自己的腿给弄伤。我也是。他把裤子剪成了短裤。然后他决定用多余的布料做一顶帽子。
His jacket can be a backpack. He's just saying the craziest things and he has destroyed his pants. We got a lot of mail about that scene from Jordan Y, Mary Triggs and Colby Shannon. They wanted to know was Steve really cutting his pants? Was the costume rigged in some way? I reached out to Steve because like you, Angela, I was very nervous. It looked very real. Yeah.
他的夹克可以当背包。他嘴里一直说着最疯狂的话，而且他的裤子已经毁了。我们收到了很多关于那场戏的邮件，来自乔丹·Y、玛丽·特里格斯和科尔比·夏农。他们想知道史蒂夫是不是真的在剪他的裤子？服装是不是在某种程度上做了手脚？我联系了史蒂夫，因为我和你一样，安吉拉，我当时非常紧张。看起来太真实了。对啊。
Steve said the costume was not rigged. He cut his pants with a real knife. Shut up! He said it was, in hindsight, it was a truly stupid thing to do. He kind of can't believe that he did it. I cannot believe this. We would have a freaking safety meeting for a lit candle. And now Steve is cutting his pants open in the middle of nowhere, by the way.
史蒂夫说服装没有做手脚。他是用真正的刀剪的裤子。闭嘴！他说回想起来，这真的是一件极其愚蠢的事。他简直不敢相信自己居然这么做了。我简直不敢相信。我们为一根点燃的蜡烛都要开个该死的安全会议。而现在史蒂夫竟然在荒郊野岭把自己的裤子割开，顺便说一句。
If he did cut his leg, they were far from anything. Yeah. Steve really likes this moment, though, he said. It makes him laugh because in the movie Castaway, Tom Hanks does this and that's kind of where he got the idea. But Tom Hanks does it after he's been on the deserted island for like two years. And Michael does it after 35 minutes. Listen, lady, I think we should take a break.
如果他真的割到腿，他们离哪儿都远。是的。不过史蒂夫真的很喜欢这个时刻，他说。这让他大笑，因为在电影《荒岛余生》中，汤姆·汉克斯就是这么做的，他的灵感大概就是这么来的。但汤姆·汉克斯是在荒岛上待了大约两年之后才这么做的。而迈克尔是在35分钟后。听着，女士，我想我们该休息一下了。
And when we come back, we're going to discuss some cake drama. Oh, I can't wait. I still can't believe he cut his own pants with that knife. I know. He specifically told me he did not use stunt legs. Oh my God. Stunt legs or a stunt knife. No stunt legs, no stunt knife, and no tear away clothes, that was all real.
等我们回来后，我们要讨论一下蛋糕风波。哦，我已经迫不及待了。我还是不敢相信他用那把刀割了自己的裤子。我知道。他专门告诉我他没有用替身腿。哦天哪。替身腿或替身刀。没有替身腿，没有替身刀，也没有撕拉式服装，全都是真的。
We are back and we have cake wars, cake wars at Dunder Mifflin, and not the fun kind where they decorate a great cake. Exactly. No, everyone wants their own cake. Meredith is like, listen, I want Devil's Food Cake. Jim's like, no problem. And then this ticks off Creed. Creed is like, it is my actual birthday.
我们回来了，邓德米夫林迎来了蛋糕大战，蛋糕大战，而且可不是那种装饰精美蛋糕的有趣的那种。完全正确。不，每个人都想要自己的蛋糕。梅雷迪思说，听着，我要魔鬼蛋糕。吉姆说，没问题。然后这就把克里德惹毛了。克里德说，这才是我的真正的生日。
Like Meredith doesn't get to pick the cake. I don't like Devil's Food Cake. I want Peach Pie. I absolutely love Jim and Creed scene together. It's done in this very different style. It looks totally different from any other scene. It's uptight and close, Creed's super intense. It reminds me of like an Aaron Sorkin kind of moment where it's like ret-ta-ta-ta dialogue
凭什么梅雷迪思不能选蛋糕。我不喜欢魔鬼蛋糕。我要桃子派。我绝对喜欢吉姆和克里德在一起的对手戏。它的拍摄风格非常独特。它看起来和任何其他场景都完全不同。气氛紧张而紧凑，克里德超级专注。这让我想起了亚伦·索尔金式的那种时刻，就像机关枪一样的对话。
back and forth. And he's like, listen, tell Angela it's for Creed, she'll know what it means. Can I say something controversial? What? You don't like Aaron Sorkin? I love Aaron Sorkin. I don't like Peach Pie. Oh.
你来我往。然后他说，听着，告诉安吉拉这是给克里德的，她会明白是什么意思。我能说点有争议的话吗？什么？你不喜欢亚伦·索尔金？我爱亚伦·索尔金。我不喜欢桃子派。哦。
I don't like any kind of peach in a dessert. Wow. I love every other cobbler. I love berry cobbler, apples. Whatever you want to throw in there, no peaches for me. I don't know what it is. If it's a peach, I want it to stay a peach and I want to eat it as a peach. I'm not interested in it being desertified.
我不喜欢甜点里有任何桃子。哇。我喜欢其他所有的果盘。我喜欢浆果果盘，苹果。不管你想往里面扔什么，别放桃子就行，我不要桃子。我不知道为什么。如果是桃子，我就想让它保持桃子的原样，我想把它当桃子吃。我对它被做成甜点不感兴趣。
What is that? I don't know. I don't know. I don't know what that is. I mean, do you like, like, do they do peach jam? I don't want peach as a jam. Okay. I love how strongly you feel about it.
那是什么？我不知道。我不知道。我不知道那是什么。我是说，你喜欢，比如说，他们做桃子果酱吗？我不要桃子做成的果酱。好吧。我喜欢你对此如此强烈的感觉。
I have very Angela Martin-esque feelings about how peaches are to be prepared. Can I share something with you? What? Okay, Jenna, this is a snarky moment for me. I'm going to share it with you and everyone listening. Okay. My whole entire life, I'm a summer birthday. So when I was growing up, they would like have the birthday celebration of whoever
对于桃子该如何制作，我有着非常安吉拉·马丁式的感受。我能跟你分享点事吗？什么？好吧，珍娜，对我来说这是一个刻薄的时刻。我要把它分享给你和所有听众。好吧。我一整个生命中，我是一个夏天生日。所以当我长大的时候，他们会庆祝谁的生日。
at school. It was their birthday, right? It would be like some kind of birthday snack or you'd wear a birthday crown or whatever it was that your classroom did, right? Yeah. I never got one. Because I had a summer birthday and guess what, guys? If you grew up in the 70s and 80s, there was no like, this is for all the summer birthday
在学校里。今天是他们的生日，对吧？会有某种生日零食，或者你会戴上生日王冠，或者不管你们教室做什么，对吧？是的。我从来没有得到过。因为我是夏天生日，你们猜怎么着，伙计们？如果你在70年代和80年代长大，根本没有什么，这是给所有夏天生日的人准备的
celebration. They didn't give a crap. You had a summer birthday. You didn't get any kind of celebration at school. Nowadays, if you have a summer birthday, they do a little thing for the kids with the summer birthdays, not when I was growing up. Cut to our time on the office. Nine years, Jenna, nine years, I watched all of you guys get a birthday cake.
庆祝活动。他们才不在乎呢。你夏天过生日。你在学校里根本得不到任何庆祝。现在，如果你夏天过生日，他们会为夏天过生日的孩子们做点小活动，我小的时候可没有。切到我们在《办公室》的时光。九年，珍娜，九年，我看着你们所有人都有生日蛋糕。
Oh no. I watched the whole entire cast and crew gather around and clap and sing happy birthday and take pictures and Peter and Vartan would make a special cake for the birthday person. Nine years. Yep. We never shot the office in June, did we, Angela? Never shot the office in June. Guess who never got the office birthday cake?
哦，不。我看着整个剧组和工作人员聚在一起鼓掌、唱生日歌、拍照，彼得和瓦尔坦会为过生日的人做一个特别的蛋糕。九年。是的。我们从来没有在六月拍过《办公室》，对吧，安吉拉？从来没有在六月拍过《办公室》。你猜谁从来没有得到过办公室的生日蛋糕？
Oh no. Me. Oh gosh. I never got it. I remember, like around season eight, they rolled out a cake for someone. Everyone's clapping and singing. And I literally said out loud, no one ever did this for me. Oh no.
哦，不。我。哦天哪。我从来没有得到过。我记得，大概在第八季左右，他们为一个什么人推出了一个蛋糕。每个人都在鼓掌唱歌。我真的大声说出来了，从来没有人为我做过这个。哦，不。
Clearly so bitter. And someone else was like, yeah, I have a summer birthday. Where's our summer birthday cake? Did they ever do it? No. I have never gotten a birthday cake at school or work. This is my Crimea River. But when I see these scenes, I just remember like being like, yeah, well, where's my f***ing
显然太痛苦了。然后另一个人说，对啊，我也是夏天生日。我们的夏天生日蛋糕在哪里？他们做过吗？没有。我从来没有在学校或工作时得到过生日蛋糕。这就是我的哭诉。但当我看到这些场景时，我只记得当时心里想，好吧，那我的该死的蛋糕在哪里？
cake? Oh my God. Lady, I'm so sorry. You're right. I enjoyed many a March birthday cake by Peter and Vartan with the candles. Sometimes they would do a photo cake and put some sweet personal photo on it. Jenna, I have multiple photos I took of other people in their cakes. Oh no.
哦天哪。女士，我很抱歉。你说得对。我享受过很多次由彼得和瓦尔坦带着蜡烛制作的三月生日蛋糕。有时他们会做一个照片蛋糕，上面放一些甜蜜的个人照片。珍娜，我有我拍的其他人拿着他们的蛋糕的多张照片。哦，不。
We also did it for the crew members. I know. Yeah. Summer birthdays, S-O-L. So listen, I turn 50 in June. I expect an office lady's birthday cake and a song and applause. Okay. Done.
我们还为剧组成员这样做过。我知道。是的。夏天生日，没戏。所以听着，我六月份就满50岁了。我期待一个办公室女士的生日蛋糕，还有一首歌和掌声。好吧。一言为定。
Did you get that, Sam, Cassie, Cody? For once in my life, I want to work birthday. You know what, Angela? I promise we will not take a vacation the week of your birthday just so that we are forced to celebrate it. I want to work on my birthday. Yeah, that's the other thing. Everyone else is like, dude, at least you were like on vacation for your birthday.
你听到了吗，萨姆、卡西、科迪？我这辈子头一次想要一个工作生日。你知道吗，安吉拉？我保证我们不会在你生日的那周去度假，就是为了逼自己去庆祝它。我想在生日那天工作。对，还有一件事。其他人都会说，老兄，至少你生日那天去度假了。
I was stuck at work. At least I got a cake. I want to work on my birthday and I want a cake. We'll make that happen for you this year, Angela. I promise. Thank you. I really appreciate it. Should we talk about Andy's cake demand?
我被困在工作岗位上。至少我得到了一个蛋糕。我想在生日那天工作，我想要一个蛋糕。我们今年一定为你实现这个愿望，安吉拉。我保证。谢谢。我真的很感激。我们应该谈谈安迪对蛋糕的要求吗？
Yes. He wants a fudgy the whale ice cream cake and pizza rolls and mushroom caps. Oh, lady. Do you remember the fudgy the whale? Do you remember this on set? It was a big deal. I do because it's a special cake brand. Yes.
好的。他想要一个福吉鲸冰激凌蛋糕、披萨卷和蘑菇帽。哦，女士。你还记得福吉鲸吗？你在片场还记得这个吗？这可是个大事件。我记得，因为这是一个特殊的蛋糕品牌。是的。
It's Carvel, right? And I had never heard of fudgy the whale, which I remember a few of the crew and Cass were like, are you kidding me? You've never heard of fudgy the whale? But it was an East Coast thing. I'd never heard of it. It's totally an East Coast thing. Well, last night, somebody might have done what she likes to call a mini dive.
是卡维尔，对吧？我以前从未听说过福吉鲸，我记得一些剧组人员和卡斯曾说，你在开玩笑吧？你从来没听说过福吉鲸吗？但这完全是东海岸的东西。我从来没听说过。这绝对是东海岸的东西。好吧，昨晚，有人可能做了一件她喜欢称之为迷你潜水的事。
Oh, you mini-dived fudgy the whale. I mean, that does sound inappropriate, but I like it. There you go. All right. Here's everything you need to know about fudgy the whale. Carvel was founded by Tom Carvel, who, by the way, is fascinating. That would be a whole other deep dive about his life and how he really gave birth to like this whole franchise ice cream phenomenon.
哦，你迷你潜水了福吉鲸。我是说，这听起来确实不太合适，但我喜欢。这就对了。好的。关于福吉鲸，你需要知道的一切都在这里。卡维尔由汤姆·卡维尔创立，顺便说一句，他非常迷人。关于他的生活以及他是如何真正催生出整个冰激凌特许经营现象的，那将是另一次深入探讨。
But here's the famous story. It's on their website. It's in multiple places online. Even has it, Tom Carvel had an ice cream truck that broke down and his ice cream started to melt. So he was really trying quickly to sell off all this ice cream before it melted. And he found that the customers actually liked it soft. So he was like, wait a second.
但这里有个著名的故事。它在他们的网站上。在网上的多个地方都能找到。甚至还有，汤姆·卡维尔有一辆冰激凌卡车坏了，他的冰激凌开始融化了。所以他真的很想在冰激凌融化之前迅速把它卖掉。他发现顾客其实挺喜欢它变软的。所以他当时想，等等。
And he started serving soft serve ice cream. And no one else was doing that. And so it became a whole thing, right? He developed a soft serve ice cream machine. He even patented it. He sold it to other franchises. This man, Jenna. He was a boss lady.
然后他开始提供软冰激凌。当时没有其他人这么做。所以这就成了一个大趋势，对吧？他开发了一台软冰激凌机。他甚至还申请了专利。他把它卖给了其他连锁店。这个男人，珍娜。他是个大老板。
He was a boss dude. He was a boss daddy. There we go. He was a boss daddy. And he started the very first Carvel ice cream shop on the exact spot where his truck broke down. That is boss daddy. So there are Carvel stores, they're franchised.
他是个大佬。他是个老大爹。这就对了。他是个老大爹。他在卡车抛锚的那个确切地点创办了第一家卡维尔冰激凌店。那才是真正的老大爹。所以有卡维尔商店，它们是特许经营的。
There is one now in Los Angeles, Jenna. Really? There used to not be, but there is one now in Los Angeles. And they became famous for a few cakes. In the 70s, they created this cake called the Cookie Puss. Oh boy. I know. The Hug Me Bear.
洛杉矶现在有一家了，珍娜。真的吗？过去没有，但现在洛杉矶有一家了。它们因几种蛋糕而闻名。在70年代，他们创造了一种叫做“饼干脸”的蛋糕。哦，天哪。我知道。“拥抱熊”。
And then Fudgy the Whale followed in June of 1977. He was all Tom Carvel's idea. He was like, we need a cake for Father's Day. I want it to be a whale. And I want the slogan to say, for a whale of a dad. Oh my God, I am loving so much about this. I looked up the expression. I'd never heard of this, a whale of a something.
然后在1977年6月推出了福吉鲸。这全都是汤姆·卡维尔的主意。他当时说，我们需要一个父亲节的蛋糕。我想要一只鲸鱼。我希望标语是，送给超棒的爸爸。哦天哪，我对这个的很多方面都爱不释手。我查了这个表达。我以前没听过这个，一头……什么的鲸鱼。
I don't know if you've heard of that expression. I hadn't. But that was an expression and it referred to a very great amount of something or a very good thing. So to be a whale of a dad was, you were a great dad, right? Fudgy the Whale was so successful. They kept the mold and talk about reuse, repurpose. At Christmas time, they flipped Fudgy the Whale on its head and made his tail like the
我不知道你有没有听过这个表达。我没有。但这是一个表达，指的是某事数量非常巨大或非常好的东西。所以成为一个超棒的爸爸就是，你是一个伟大的爸爸，对吧？福吉鲸太成功了。他们保留了模具，说到重复使用、物尽其用。在圣诞节的时候，他们把福吉鲸倒过来，把它的尾巴做成圣诞老人的帽子，把它变成了一个圣诞老人。直到今天，你仍然可以买到福吉鲸，你还可以买到雌性的福吉鲸。
Santa hat and made him into a Santa. And to this day, you can still get Fudgy the Whale and you can also get a female Fudgy the Whale. They'll give her pink piping and like eyelashes and a little bow and more than 50,000 Fudgy the Whale ice cream cakes are sold every year. All the cakes come with two layers of chocolate and vanilla separated by a layer of what they call crunchies. They don't tell you what's in their crunchy recipe and you can customize it with favorite
他们会给她画上粉红色的花边、睫毛和一个小蝴蝶结，每年售出超过5万个福吉鲸冰激凌蛋糕。所有的蛋糕都有两层巧克力和香草，中间夹着一层他们称之为“脆脆”的东西。他们不会告诉你他们脆脆的配方里有什么，你可以用最喜欢的口味和不同类型的夹心来定制它，这就是福吉鲸。但我还有一件事想放给你听。汤姆·卡维尔本人会为福吉鲸制作所有的叮咚广告歌和广告。
flavors and a different type of center and there you have it. That's Fudgy the Whale. But I have one other thing I want to play you. Tom Carvel himself would do all the jingles and commercials for Fudgy the Whale. No way! Yep. All right, Jenna. Here's Tom Carvel talking about Fudgy the Whale for their ad.
没门！是的。好了，珍娜。这是汤姆·卡维尔在他们的广告中谈论福吉鲸。
Fudgy the Whale is back. That's a whale of a cake for a whale of a dad that you participate in Carvel Ice Cream Store. Yeah. And this year, your Carvel Nealer makes you loaded with Fudge and nuts and you can get a Fudgey the Whale with an ocean to serve 20 people and if you want to send Fudgey the Whale to a whale of a dad anywhere in Carvel territory, you call them the phone number that you see here.
福吉鲸回来了。那是一个献给超棒爸爸的超棒蛋糕，你可以在卡维尔冰激凌店参与。是的。今年，你的卡维尔经销商为你准备了满满的软糖和坚果，你可以买到一个带海洋的福吉鲸来招待20个人，如果你想把福吉鲸送给卡维尔服务区内的任何一个超棒的爸爸，你就可以拨打你在这里看到的电话号码。
Thank you and have a happy day, dad. I don't want to tip my hand too much. Am I going to get a Fudgey the Whale for my 50th birthday? How could we not get you a Fudgey the Whale now? Oh my God. I am so excited already. I want to eat one of those so bad now that you've described it. I know.
谢谢你，祝爸爸节日快乐。我不想过早透露我的底牌。我能为我的50岁生日得到一个福吉鲸吗？我们现在怎么能不给你买一个福吉鲸呢？哦天哪。我已经太兴奋了。既然你描述得这么好，我现在太想吃一个了。我知道。
I went on Carvel's website. There's so many cool looking cakes. They do a lot more now. I'm not going to lie. The cookie puss is kind of odd looking. What is it? A cat? I took a picture of it.
我上了卡维尔的网站。有那么多看起来很酷的蛋糕。他们现在做更多了。我不会撒谎。饼干脸看起来有点奇怪。那是什么？一只猫？我拍了一张照片。
Here were their first three cakes that were like their famous cakes. Okay. I can't wait for you to see this. This is the cookie puss. Oh, well, it has a full ice cream cone as a nose. Yeah. And then on its cheeks, it has little arms drawn on it, it has cookies for eyes. Are they arms?
这里是他们的前三种蛋糕，就像他们的著名蛋糕一样。好吧。我等不及让你看看这个了。这是饼干脸。哦，好吧，它有一个完整的冰激凌蛋卷作为鼻子。是的。然后在它的脸颊上，画着小胳膊，用饼干当眼睛。那是胳膊吗？
What's the puss part? Is it meant to be a cat? I don't know. I don't understand what it is. Here's the best part. For St. Patrick's Day, you can get a cookie opus, the Irish version. I don't understand it. I want to eat it.
“脸”的部分是什么？是打算做成一只猫吗？我不知道。我搞不懂那是什么。这是最棒的部分。在圣帕特里克节，你可以买到一个饼干大脸，爱尔兰版本的。我搞不懂。我想吃它。
I don't know. I went real deep onto the Carvel site, but I'm very excited. I want to fudge you the whale for my 50th birthday. Done. I can't wait. I don't remember it being on set. Isn't that funny? I remember everyone talking about it and I remember people saying, what is it?
我不知道。我深入研究了卡维尔的网站，但我非常兴奋。我想要一个福吉鲸作为我的50岁生日蛋糕。一言为定。我等不及了。我不记得它在片场出现过。不觉得这很搞笑吗？我记得每个人都在谈论它，我记得人们在说，那是什么？
But I don't remember ever having one. I totally remember it. I mean, my character didn't eat it, but I remember Ed eating it in the scene. Wow. Well, when we eat your cake for your birthday, it's going to be all new to me. Lady, should we go back out into the wilderness? Oh, definitely we should. I have a crew catch at 13 minutes 15 seconds.
但我实在记不起自己吃过。我完全记得。我是说，我的角色没有吃，但我记得埃德在场景里吃了。哇。好吧，当我们吃你的生日蛋糕时，这一切对我来说都是崭新的。女士，我们应该回到荒野中去吗？哦，我们绝对应该。我在13分15秒处有一个剧组穿帮。
Oh, what'd you catch? You can see our cinematographer Randall Einhorn's hand come into frame and brush some tree branches away that were probably going to hit his camera. He's walking behind Dwight. Oh, Jenna, that's a great catch. I didn't see that. What's the time code? 13 minutes 15 seconds.
哦，你抓到了什么？你可以看到我们的摄影师兰德尔·艾因霍恩的手进入画面，拨开了一些可能会撞到他的摄像机的树枝。他正走在德怀特后面。哦，珍娜，真是个伟大的发现。我没看到。时间码是多少？13分15秒。
I was not the only person to catch it, but I want to say that I saw it before I saw our male, but Tim Wong, Jonah T, Addy H, and Keanna Raeber also wrote in about Randall's hand. Well, great job, guys. Great job. We also had Jasper Anders and Morgan Elridge write in to ask, what did Phil Shea use for the bird eggs that Dwight finds and cooks? They kind of look like they might be small potatoes. Guess what?
我不是唯一一个发现的人，但我想说，我在看到我们的邮件之前就看到了，不过蒂姆·王、乔纳·T、阿迪·H和基安娜·雷伯也写信来提到了兰德尔的手。好吧，干得好，伙计们。干得漂亮。我们还有杰斯珀·安德斯和摩根·埃尔德里奇写信来问，菲尔·谢伊用什么来做德怀特找到并烹饪的鸟蛋？它们看起来有点像小土豆。你猜怎么着？
What? They were small potatoes. Really? Teeny tiny potatoes meant to look like eggs. I totally thought they were eggs, but I was trying to think what kind of bird makes a nest like that up in a tree. What? What?
什么？它们就是小土豆。真的吗？极小的土豆，用来假装是蛋。我完全以为那是蛋，但我一直在想，什么鸟会在树上筑那样一个巢？什么？什么？
Many birds? So many birds? That was such a big nest, though. Like those eggs look like a bird that would like lay them on the ground, to me. Or I would, I mean, I guess, what? Or maybe they're the eggs of a bird that would nest really up high. Exactly. They didn't look like the type of eggs that you could just reach with your hand.
许多鸟？这么多的鸟？不过那是个好大的巢。我觉得那些蛋看起来像那种会把蛋产在地面上的鸟的蛋。或者我会，我是说，我猜，什么？或者它们可能是那种会在非常高的树上筑巢的鸟的蛋？没错。它们看起来不像是那种你伸手就能够到的蛋。
I think you would either find them on the ground or they'd be up on a cliff top. I think that that's a good way to say it. When you said what kind of bird lays eggs in a tree, I was confused. This is my mom. But I'm hearing your point now, and I hear it, and I think it's a good point. Thank you. I need to talk about this shot of Michael singing Happy Birthday because it is just wonderful. Michael has just made a spear, the teeniest, tiniest spear on the end of a very crooked
我觉得你要么会在地上找到它们，要么它们会在悬崖顶上。我觉得这是一种很好的说法。当你问什么鸟在树上产卵时，我很困惑。这是我妈。但我现在听到了你的观点，我听进去了，我觉得这是一个好观点。谢谢。我得谈谈迈克尔唱生日歌的这个镜头，因为实在是太棒了。迈克尔刚刚做了一根长矛，在一根非常弯曲的木棍的顶端，做了一根极细极细的长矛。
stick. Can you point out that he made a spear when he has an amazing knife, like you would think he would attach the knife to the end of the stick? With his duct tape, with his duct tape, he might have used all his duct tape to fashion his tent out of his pants. That's coming up, I guess. But yeah, there's this shot that pulls so far back. And what's amazing about it to me is, guys, Steve was really in the middle of nowhere
你能指出他居然做了一把长矛，而他有一把绝妙的刀，你本以为他会把刀绑在棍子顶上吗？用他的胶带，用他的胶带，他可能把所有的胶带都用来用裤子做帐篷了。我想这就要演到了。但，是的，这个镜头拉得非常远。对我来说，这个镜头最厉害的地方在于，伙计们，史蒂夫真的是在荒郊野岭，而正如这个镜头所显示的，我们的剧组离得很远。
and our crew was far back as this shot reveals. Yeah. I thought it was a beautiful shot. I also love these moments when Michael remembers things like sprinkles, like Creed's birthday. You know, when he sings a song and he's like, Happy Birthday, buddy. These are those very sweet Michael moments. This shot also made me think about how Steve Carell wrote this episode. He wrote himself a very difficult shoot day out in the woods.
是的。我觉得这是一个美丽的镜头。我也很喜欢这些时刻，当迈克尔想起诸如糖针之类的事情时，比如克里德的生日。你知道，当他唱起歌，他说，生日快乐，老兄。这些都是非常甜蜜的迈克尔时刻。这个镜头也让我想起史蒂夫·卡莱尔是如何编写这一集的。他为自己在树林里写了一个非常艰难的拍摄日。
He did, where he gets tackled by Dwight. Oh my gosh. If I were writing an episode for myself, I would make it pajama day at the office, where we all wear our pajamas and there are no stunts. I would write a very different episode, so I applaud Steve for really going for it in the name of comedy. Back in the office, we have bitching in the break room. Oh, I love this.
他确实这么做了，在那里他被德怀特扑倒。哦，天哪。如果我要为自己写一集，我会把它写成办公室的睡衣日，我们都穿着睡衣，没有任何特技。我会写一集非常不同的剧集，所以我为史蒂夫在喜剧的名义下真正全力以赴鼓掌。回到办公室，我们在休息室里发牢骚。哦，我太喜欢这个了。
Everyone is in the break room and they are complaining about Jim's new birthday ordinance. And it's just a gripe fest. Look what I wrote as part of the scene. I've never had a cake at work for my birthday. Wow. As everyone was griping about the cakes and the birthdays. Angela, this episode really triggered you. Really so.
每个人都在休息室里，他们都在抱怨吉姆的新生日条例。这简直就是一场抱怨大会。看看我作为场景一部分写的东西。我过生日时在公司从来没有吃过蛋糕。哇。当大家都在抱怨蛋糕和生日时。安吉拉，这一集真的把你气到了。确实如此。
Right about this time, Jim walks in and Creed delivers some major sass. Oh, Creed sass. Some real, real good passive aggressive sass from Creed. And right after some real serious Creed sass, Jim is going to have to deal with Toby. Oh, this is such a good scene. It's so good and you see in Jim's eyes, oh my God, Michael, I get it. Yeah. He has a talking head where he says, you know, Toby is sometimes a bit much.
就在这个时候，吉姆走了进来，克里德发表了一些极具讽刺意味的言论。哦，克里德的讽刺。来自克里德的一些非常非常好的被动攻击式的讽刺。就在一些非常严重的克里德式讽刺之后，吉姆不得不应付托比。哦，这真是一场好戏。太棒了，你从吉姆的眼里看出来，哦天哪，迈克尔，我懂了。是的。有一个单人访谈，他说，你知道，托比有时候有点过分。
Yeah. Well, listen, Toby's birthday is not right now and he's piling on Jim. He says, I'd really like to be included because when we did celebrate my birthday, it was in the parking lot at 4.58 p.m. And so Toby would now like to be included. Jenna, am I the Toby of this moment today? No, am I the Toby? Am I like, I know it's not my birthday, but I want to be included.
是的。好吧，听着，现在不是托比的生日，他却在给吉姆施压。他说，我真的很想被包括在内，因为当我们庆祝我的生日时，是在下午4点58分的停车场。所以托比现在也想被包括在内。珍娜，我今天是这时的托比吗？不，我是托比吗？我是那种，我知道这不是我的生日，但我想要被算在内的人吗？
Am I the Toby? Well, you're not asking us to throw you a party on someone else's birthday. You're just saying, this year, don't skip my effin birthday just because it's in the summer. I think it's very different. Thank you. Jim agrees to just add Toby to the mix and Angela overhears this. She's so furious.
我是托比吗？嗯，你又不是让我们在别人的生日那天给你办派对。你只是说，今年，别因为我的生日在夏天就跳过我该死的生日。我觉得这很不一样。谢谢。吉姆同意把托比加进来，安吉拉无意中听到了这一点。她太生气了。
She's like, you can't go willy-nilly with all of this, Jim. You know, we already have several cakes and a pie and mushroom caps. And Toby's like, I'm allergic to mushrooms. Well, that's the last straw. Jim storms out of his office and he says, conference room. And Pam's like, five minutes. And he's like, yes, conference room, five minutes. And he's like, no.
她说，吉姆，你不能随心所欲地搞这些。你知道的，我们已经有好几个蛋糕、一个派和蘑菇帽了。而托比却说，我对蘑菇过敏。好吧，这真是最后一根稻草了。吉姆冲出办公室，他说，会议室。潘说，五分钟。他说，对，会议室，五分钟。然后他说，不。
I mean, no, we're going to deal with this right here. I have something to point out in this scene. It's a little background catch. Mm-hmm. Both Creed and Meredith have a free-sell game open on their computer. I have a little background catch in this scene as well at 17 minutes 36 seconds. I am leaning up against Michael's doorframe, standing next to Toby, and you can see the beginning of my baby belly.
我是说，不，我们就在这里处理这件事。在这场戏里我有一点要指出。这是一个背景小穿帮。嗯。克里德和梅雷迪思的电脑上都开着一个纸牌游戏。我在17分36秒的这个场景中也有一个小背景穿帮。我靠在迈克尔的门框上，站在托比旁边，你可以看到我的孕肚的开始。
Oh my gosh, are you serious? I am serious. And I rewatched this episode with my daughter, and I didn't say anything to her. And as she was watching it with me, we got to the scene and she said, mom, is this when you were pregnant with me? And I said, it was. Look, Jenna. Oh my gosh.
哦天哪，你是认真的吗？我是认真的。我和我女儿一起重温了这一集，我什么都没对她说。当她和我一起看时，我们看到了这个场景，她说，妈妈，这是你怀着我的时候吗？我说，是的。看，珍娜。哦，天哪。
And you have your hands in front of your stomach to kind of try to hide it. But Angie, I thought I could kind of see it earlier in the episode when you have your first scene walking up to Jim's desk. Really? I tried to position you a little bit behind his computer screen, but maybe because I know I felt like I had a belly spot. Well this will be the beginning of the belly tracking because we had to get really creative over the next few weeks.
而且你把手放在肚子前面，试图把它藏起来。但安吉，我以为我在早些时候的场景中就能看到一点，就是你第一次走到吉姆桌子前的那个镜头。真的吗？我试着把你稍微安排在他的电脑屏幕后面，但也许是因为我知道，我觉得自己有一个孕肚。好吧，这将是肚子追踪的开始，因为在接下来的几周里，我们必须进行真正的创造性发挥。
I'm ready to head back out to the forest, Angela. Okay. Because I have a lot to say about this scene where Michael finds some mushrooms growing under a tree and he starts to eat them and Dwight tackles him and forces them out of his mouth. Mm-hmm. It's pretty amazing. It's so great.
我已经准备好回到森林里去了，安吉拉。好吧。因为关于迈克尔在一棵树下发现了一些蘑菇并开始吃它们，而德怀特扑倒他并强行把它们从他嘴里抠出来的这场戏，我有很多话要说。嗯。这太神奇了。太棒了。
I had to know more about these mushrooms. What'd you find out? According to Dundrpedia, the species of mushroom that Michael was about to eat are called hypheloma fasciculare. I'm sure I got that wrong. I would never be able to say that. They are more commonly known as the clustered wood lover. Okay.
我必须对这些蘑菇有更多了解。你发现了什么？根据邓德百科全书，迈克尔正要吃的蘑菇的种类被称为“簇生黄伞”。我敢肯定我读错了。我绝对念不出那个词。它们更广为人知的名字是“丛生木生菌”。好吧。
I deep dived on these mushrooms. I'm guessing they grow on wood. They do. It is a type of mushroom and they grow on rotten trees, stumps, or trunks. The taste is very bitter if you eat them raw, but they are not bitter if you cook them. They are poisonous either way, cooked or raw. Why would anyone cook them if they're poisonous? How do we even know what they taste like?
我深入研究了这些蘑菇。我猜它们生长在木头上。它们确实是。这是一种蘑菇，它们生长在腐烂的树木、树桩或树干上。如果你生吃它们，味道会非常苦，但如果你煮熟了，它们就不苦了。无论煮熟还是生吃，它们都有剧毒。既然有毒，为什么还有人煮它们？我们甚至怎么知道它们是什么味道的？
I'll tell you, because a common poisoning technique would be to cook these mushrooms with non-poisonous mushrooms and then feed them to your enemy, and it's sort of like an undetectable way to poison someone to death. So morbid. So clearly this has been done. Yeah. Did you see the movie Phantom Thread starring Daniel Day Lewis because this is a plot point in the movie?
我来告诉你，因为一种常见的下毒手法是将这些蘑菇与无毒的蘑菇一起煮，然后喂给你的敌人，这有点像是一种无法察觉的毒死某人的方法。太病态了。所以很显然，这已经有人干过了。是的。你看过丹尼尔·戴-刘易斯主演的电影《魅影缝匠》吗？因为这也是电影中的一个情节。
No. And if you tell me to watch it, I'm going to watch the movie. It's the first 15 minutes of it. Well, you're going to miss the mushrooms because they happen later. Let me tell you. What? Here's what happens to you if you eat these mushrooms. Okay.
没有。如果你让我去看，我就会去看这部电影。这是电影的前15分钟。好吧，你会错过蘑菇的，因为它们发生在后面。让我告诉你。什么？如果你吃了这些蘑菇，会发生以下情况。好吧。
Diarrhea. Okay. Nausea. Mmm. Vomiting. Well. Convulsions. Oh.
腹泻。好吧。恶心。嗯。呕吐。好吧。惊厥。哦。
Impaired vision. Hmm. Paralysis. Oh. And collapse. It can take up to five to 10 hours before you get symptoms. Now most of the time the symptoms will resolve themselves after a few days, but you get real sick, but they can cause death if you eat too many.
视力受损。嗯。瘫痪。哦。还有虚脱。出现症状可能需要5到10小时。现在大多数时候症状在几天后会自行消失，但你会病得很重，如果你吃得太多，它们会导致死亡。
So guys, spoiler alert. Phantom Thread is an amazing movie. Everyone should watch it. I'm not going to watch it. As if anyone's ever going to take my movie recommendations again. I did watch this one all the way through twice. I loved it so much. Stop listening here for 10 seconds if you don't want me to spoil the movie for you,
所以伙计们，剧透警告。《魅影缝匠》是一部精彩绝伦的电影。每个人都应该看。我不打算看。好像还会有人再接受我的电影推荐一样。这部我从头到尾看了两遍。我太喜欢它了。如果你不想让我剧透，在这里停止收听10秒钟，
but someone gets poisoned with mushrooms. Do they have a little towel by their coffee pot? No. But they have a wonderful English kitchen that looks like it's really fun to cook in. So there is some great shots of a great kitchen. I'll be sure and check out the shots of the kitchen. Oh my God. Oh, dear.
但是有人用蘑菇中毒了。他们的咖啡机旁边有一条小毛巾吗？没有。但他们有一个绝妙的英国厨房，看起来在里面做饭真的很有趣。所以有一些关于一个好厨房的精彩镜头。我一定得去看看厨房的镜头。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。
Let John Wick go, Angela, let it go. Maybe once you get your Carvel cake, you'll forgive me. Once I join everyone who's ever celebrated their birthday at work or school. Anyway, that is the download on the mushrooms. Well, you know the scene where Dwight tackles Michael to the ground? Yeah. There was much more of this in the deleted scenes. There's a great talking head where Michael's like, you know, when Dwight tackled me to
放过《疾速追杀》吧，安吉拉，算了吧。也许等你拿到卡维尔蛋糕，你就会原谅我了。一旦我加入所有在工作或学校庆祝过生日的人的行列。不管怎样，这就是关于蘑菇的全部情报。好吧，你知道德怀特把迈克尔扑倒在地的那个场景吗？对。在被删减的片段里，这部分内容要多得多。有一个很棒的单人访谈，迈克尔说，你知道的，当德怀特把我扑倒在地，用手指从我嘴里掏出蘑菇时，他是这么说的。他好像说，当德怀特的的手指伸进我嘴里时，我躺下来看着天空，小鸟在叽叽喳喳地叫，有云彩，真是太美了。然后我吐了，因为真的很恶心。当德怀特试图把蘑菇从他嘴里掏出来时，他能有这种美丽动人的时刻，真是太搞笑了。我不得不问，那是单人访谈吗？
the ground and was fishing the mushrooms out of my mouth with his finger, he like says it. He's like, when Dwight had his finger in my mouth, he said, I laid back and I looked at the sky and the birds were chirping and there were clouds and it was so beautiful. And then I vomited because it was really gross. It's really funny that he had this sort of beautiful moment while Dwight was trying to fish the mushrooms out of his mouth. I have to ask, is that talking head?
他穿着他那件破烂的衣服，还是穿着德怀特的运动衫？不，那大概是关于他一天的总结访谈，他穿着《太空堡垒卡拉狄加》的运动衫在办公室里。好吧，我喜欢这个主意，他的衣服破破烂烂的。他可能吐在上面了，德怀特不得不把后备箱里的这件救急运动衫借给他。好吧，珍娜，我想让你知道，在18分31秒时，当德怀特和迈克尔回来，他们走进派对，迈克尔立刻开始飙高音，对吧？
Is he wearing his torn up clothes or is he wearing Dwight's sweatshirt? No, it would have been like a wrap up talking head about his day and he was in his office with the Battlestar Galactica sweatshirt. Well, I love this idea that his clothes are tattered. He's probably vomited on them and Dwight has to give him this rescue sweatshirt that was in his trunk. Well, Jenna, I want you to know at 18 minutes 31 seconds when Dwight and Michael come back and they walk in the party and Michael immediately starts hitting those high notes, right?
他连拍子都没漏。镜头扫过会议室，托比、潘、安吉拉和奥斯卡都站在一起，他们笑得非常开心。我想，哦天哪，托比和安吉拉很高兴看到迈克尔和奥斯卡。是的。我期待潘对她笑，你知道的，但托比和安吉拉看到迈克尔能松一口气。好吧，他们并不喜欢吉姆当头儿。
He doesn't miss a beat. The camera pans the conference room and Toby, Pam, Angela and Oscar are all standing together and they are smiling so big. And I thought, oh my God, Toby and Angela are happy to see Michael and Oscar. Yeah. I expect Pam to smile at him, you know, but the fact that Toby and Angela were relieved to see Michael. Well, they did not enjoy Jim being in charge.
没有。我们在这一幕里遇到了粉丝抓包，安吉拉。好的。来自安德烈亚·T。她想知道是谁给克里德做的桃子脆皮馅饼？因为它在一个玻璃烤盘里。显然是自己做的。安吉拉是回家做了这个脆皮馅饼吗，因为她太热衷于办一场完美的生日派对？
No. We had a fan catch in this scene, Angela. Okay. From Andrea T. Who would like to know who made the peach cobbler for Creed? Because it's in a Pyrex dish. It's clearly homemade. Did Angela go home and make this cobbler because she is so dedicated to throwing the perfect birthday party?
所以听着，我也想过这个。我觉得安吉拉确实做了。我觉得当克里德对吉姆说，告诉安吉拉这是给克里德的，她会知道该怎么做时。安吉拉回家给他做了他最喜欢的桃子脆皮派。我很佩服。嗯。好吧，在18分56秒时，伙计们，有一个福吉鲸蛋糕的精彩特写。
So listen, I thought about this too. And I think Angela did. I think when Creed said to Jim, tell Angela it's for Creed, she'll know what to do. Angela went home and made his favorite peach cobbler pie. I'm impressed. Mm-hmm. Well, at 18 minutes 56 seconds, you guys, there is a great shot of the fudgy, the whale cake.
哦，所以你看。那就在那儿。福吉的证据。福吉的证据。珍娜，当我们结束这个场景时，吉姆和迈克尔有一个美妙的时刻，吉姆说，我试图把他们所有的生日放在同一天过，迈克尔说，哦，对，我做过那个。是的。
Oh, so there you go. That was there. Proof of fudgy. Proof of fudgy. And Jenna, as we're wrapping up this scene, Jim and Michael have this fantastic moment where Jim is like, I tried to do all of their parties on one day and Michael's like, oh, yeah, I did that. Yeah.
新手错误。你会搞定的。这个场景太美了。这是对迈克尔的一次窥视，他有点像是在跟同龄人说话，对吧？他总是管理着我们，或者总是想在我们面前保持那种地位。但在这里，他正在以经理对经理的身份跟吉姆交谈。太棒了。太棒了。
Rookie mistake. You'll figure it out. This scene is so beautiful. It's this glimpse into Michael where he's kind of talking to a peer, right? He's always managing us or always wanting to be in that position of status to us. But here he is talking manager on manager to Jim. It's amazing. It's so great.
这是一个非常有人情味的时刻。你知道，吉姆说，我10年后不会在这里了。迈克尔说，对，我也是这么说的。所以在我们结束这一集时，珍娜，我想我们可以听一下吉姆和迈克尔在一起的最后结局。萨姆，你能放一下那个吗？当然，很高兴你回来了。你如释重负。
And it's such a human moment. You know, Jim's like, I'm not going to be here in 10 years. And Michael's like, yeah, that's what I said. So as we close out this episode, Jenna, I thought we could hear just the final end of Jim and Michael's scene together. Sam, can you play that? Sure, glad you're back. You are relieved.
你根本不知道。那我错过了什么？好吧，我试着把所有的生日一次性一起过。哦。糟糕的主意。是的。好吧。我做过。
You have no idea. So what did I miss? Well, I tried to put all the birthdays together at once. Oh. Terrible idea. Yeah. Okay. I did that.
新手错误。你真的做过？嗯哼。不。等着瞧。10年。你会搞定的。嗯，我觉得我10年后不会在这里。
Rookie mistake. You did do it? Uh-huh. No. Just wait. 10 years. You'll figure it out. Well, I don't think I'll be here in 10 years.
我也是这么说的。她是这么说的。谁这么说的？我从来不知道。我们只管说吧。我会说这样的话，你知道的，为了在事情变得艰难时缓解紧张气氛。她是这么说的。嘿。
That's what I said. That's what she said. That's what who said? I never know. Let's just say it. I say stuff like that, you know, to lighten the tension when things sort of get hard. That's what she said. Hey.
不错。真的很好。干得好，我的年轻小伙。我有个问题。是的。迈克尔终于在吃袋子里的东西了吗？听起来他在吃坚果。是的。
Nice. Really good. Bravo, my young ward. I have a question. Yeah. Is Michael finally eating what was in the bag? It sounds like he's eating nuts. Yeah.
我看了看，感觉是，我看不出是什么，小蝴蝶结饼干。你知道它们看起来像什么吗？如果你有一包咸味混合零食，里面有这些小粗壮的蝴蝶结饼干。我不知道。或者它们看起来像切片杏仁或山核桃。这真是一个谜。但当我看着那个我绝对喜欢的可爱场景时，我在想，他在吃什么？
I looked at it and it's like, I can't tell what they are, little pretzel bites. You know what they look like? If you get a Chex mix, there are these little stubby pretzel bite things. I don't know. Or they look like slivered almonds or pecans. It's such a mystery. But as I watched that lovely scene that I absolutely love, I was wondering, what is he eating?
我都忘了这事了。我得回去看看。好吧，伙计们，那是求生专家。我觉得我在树林里可撑不下去。但我绝对能在派对策划上坚持下来。我会确保每个人都有他们该死的蛋糕。下周，我们将迎来听证会，里面有一些我这辈子最喜欢的场景。太棒了。
I'd forgotten about it. I'll have to go back and look. Well, you guys, that was survivor man. I don't think I'd make it out in the woods. I do think I'd make it at party planning. I'd make sure everyone had their dang cake. Next week, we have the deposition that has some of my favorite scenes of all time. Brilliant.
非常感谢你们的收听。谢谢你们发来的问题和评论。我们爱这个。我们爱你们。大家在安吉拉生日那天给她送个蛋糕吧。不，不，不。不，天哪。好了。
Thank you so much for listening. Thank you for sending in your questions and your comments. We love it. We love you guys. Everyone send Angela a cake on her birthday. No, no, no. No, my gosh. All right.
拜拜，伙计们。拜拜。感谢收听“办公室女士们”。“办公室女士们”由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔执行制作。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的副制作人是艾斯利·布巴科夫。
Bye, guys. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubakow.
我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。有关“办公室女士们”的无广告版本，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用Stitcher Premium一个月，请使用代码OFFICE。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可留下评论。
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。要收听《办公室女士》的无广告版本，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用 Stitcher Premium 一个月，请使用优惠码 OFFICE。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。